neben ihr steht jetzt der sprecher der
polizei in cloppenburg hendrik meyer
ihm werde ich jetzt ein paar fragen
stellen auch hinsichtlich der ursache es
ist alles sehr sehr schwierig
das ist noch nicht lange her dass man
die passiert ist können sie jetzt zum
jetzigen stand sagen hier ist dazu
kommen zu sagen haben wir noch keine
erkenntnisse was ursächlich mit diesem
schlimmen verkehrsunfall gewesen sein
könnte
zumindest zu den witterungsverhältnissen
wissen wir dass es trocken nachteil
gewesen ist
[Gelächter]
sie ist eine straße reichen freund
versehen leider der brauch nach dem
fahrzeug im wege stand dazu gab es
keinen kurvenverlauf oder anderen
besonders kleinen gerade strecken können
sie einfacher zu sagen was ich bin erst
helfern boten dort ankamen
natürlich überwältigende bilder erst
helfer und personen die nicht was du tun
haben
eine person im fahrzeug eingeklemmt wir
noch eine fahrerin und das erst
lebenswert behindern was man es mit
einer lebensgefährlich und mit den
schwerverletzten passiert in folge neben
zahlreichen notarzt und rettungswagen
waren die rettung zum schraube
eingesetzt
die lebensgefährlich verletzte gegeben
haben
hierbei auch ein traum aus niederlanden
und einer aus die wird es jetzt mit den
rettungskräften war da denen sich ja
auch bilder geboten wurden der ist eine
abend schon unmittelbar nach dem einsatz
seien die arbeiten vor ort abgeschlossen
gewesen sind auch das wird bei uns dazu
nach solchen magischen und walter
aufzuarbeiten
angehörige und erstversorgung noch an
der unfallstelle
er hat jetzt die ermittlungen übernommen
wir haben uns hier im haus brachte die
verursacher ermitteln und ihr mit luft
nur sagt an bord werden bald die lage
übernehmen und versuchen an der lage und
auch zeugenaussagen
und wir bleiben natürlich dran wenn es
neue erkenntnisse zu garten compo eine
frage habe ich trotzdem noch wie geht es
denn den kindern weiß man da schon was
kannst du die weiter leiden schweben sie
noch in lebensgefahr
morgen erreichen uns aus den
niederlanden nachricht dass leider
ordentlich die weiteren verletzten dani
alves schwer oder noch mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren